hi guys
welcome to pagaya uh very happy you're
here
um we'll see how long it takes me to
start speaking in english
correctly but uh yeah so uh
my name is uh nifty i'm
leading a data science team here in the
research in the credit research group
um today i'll talk about
statistical phenomena called the
winner's curse
something very
important in what we do and what a lot
of people do with uh statistics and
machine learning
um
yeah let's go into it okay so so first
let's talk about what it is then we'll
talk then we'll try to show it
empirically and afterwards we'll try to
understand it more thoroughly and maybe
a little bit
talk about
directions how to solve it uh
we won't really get to talk about the
solution exactly
for that you'll have to
come work here no just kidding we're not
hiring
that's a joke
we are obviously hiring so
why else do i meet up
um so yeah the winner is curse so that's
kind of a paraphrasing on
on what you can find in wikipedia but um
so basically it's a phenomenon that may
occur
when we have auctions with common value
common value means that the item is has
pretty much the same value or
same information about the value for
different players in the auction
where different players have different
signals
so you can think about signals as
features you can think about signals as
a way to model or feature engineering
and stuff like that
and
pretty much by definition the person who
wins the auction right is the highest
bidder uh
will be the most optimistic
and uh the phenomena we will examine
here it will
show that the
they often tend to overestimate
so uh the winner is curse it's a
it's a well-known term you can find it
um
it can mean a lot of different things
some people use it to
describe some psychological effects that
makes a winner overestimate but we'll
talk mainly about the statistical
statistical effects
so to sum things up
when you have a common value auction and
different signals you get overestimation
so we'll just see how it works
so where can we find this kind of
dynamic right we'll talk we're talking
about auctions with common value and
different signals
so obviously given loans that's what we
do here i was trying to do a list that
goes from the obvious to the most
like funny or weird
um so obviously giving loans there's
it's basically a bidding process where
uh
someone requests loans
request a loan
lenders give him
some interest rate which is the bidding
price
and he
would probably take the lowest one
also make an offer on a house another
training a lot of stuff even in hiring
you can think about it sort of a common
value uh beating auction and even when
you're talking about finding a spouse so
i hope this
this slide would convince you that
it's uh
important because it's in a lot of
things
okay cool so uh we'll work through a
working example
um
which would not be very important to
analysis but uh just to make things a
little bit more colorful if if people
here never
thought about auctions really so
let's say there's a new market opens up
uh where people can
bid on old books like vintage books and
the highest bidder wins so
you
like the api of the the auction would be
you get a title the addition and the
condition you obviously can enrich some
features about the author and stuff like
that we'll talk about that um you be the
price and it's a it's called the first
price sealed beat auction
which means that the winner is obviously
the highest bidder and he pays the
his bids so the highest bid
that's not always the case
and it's a still bid which means it's
not open people don't know
the other bids
so they just bid and
they know if they won or didn't
and we'll talk about a specific strategy
just because we have to for the example
but it's not really important the
strategy here would be
uh
we buy a book and we sell it after five
years we want to make profit okay so
that's pretty
simple
so let's talk about how we can build the
bidder so
so the lecture is called uh
bidding with machine learning i think
so we obviously want to use machine
learning
for that let's assume we have some
historic data set about
books right
with their features and their prices
over time
and stuff like that so
um
we'll talk about a strategy just
we want to bid the future price so we
said the strategy would be um
buying a book and selling it after five
years so let's say uh we'll just try to
bid
the price we think we'll be able to sell
it after five years
uh so that strategy would give us pretty
much neutral profit right we're buying
and selling at the same price
which
would allow us to
buy and sell the maximum volume which is
sustainable
and
as i said the strategy is not very
important here it's not really crucial
to the analysis but um
this would would be a an optimal
strategy in what's called victory
options which is you pay the second
highest
bid so uh
you can think uh why is that true
okay so um how will we do this we will
build our target right well the target
is the price after five years and we
enrich the features with all sorts of
features and we'll try to just build our
predictions
so
yeah we have obviously an historic
dataset which he keeps
okay so now we'll talk about the
simulation
first of all i'll talk about
what we want what we want to achieve in
the simulation
and it's mainly to give some intuition
about the problem maybe on ways to solve
it
and mainly about why it's so complicated
and hard
so
so we assume we have
multiple players they all play the same
strategy so they all try to predict the
same target and they bid that stagger
which is the price after five years
um
we would want all the players to have
the same information
why because that would be harder right
i'll if i'll if i'll show you that
there's a curse where some players are
blind to
information other players don't have it
won't be that interesting
i'll be more specific about what
information means
and
basically they have different feature
engineering
so we want players to have different
accuracies this is also
not very well defined but
what i'm
what i'm what i mean in accuracies here
is that they have
different um
accuracy over the whole distribution of
data
so that would be also helpful to
see some phenomenas
we want different players to be good at
different areas so you can
you can imagine that one player could be
better than the other but in some subset
of the distribution the
this fact could be the opposite way
around so
and uh and we will have one optimal
player
which might be confusing but he's not a
perfect player so he can't predict
completely accurate the target but but
he is better than every other player in
every area
um
and i'll show
how we achieve these uh
these requirements
so generating data
um
so we have items every item is described
by five features
uh the features are just samples from a
uniform form a normal distribution
we use five coefficients
and we we will only talk about linear
regressions
just to make things simple
i hope you'll convince yourself that
it's not
that the results are not dependent on
the modeling
so the coefficients will be one two
three four five
and the label
would be generated by this equation so
basically what this equation means is
that if you do the feature engineering
of
taking the power of three or cubic power
for every feature
and you use a linear regression on those
features
you would get the the best
model you can get up until the noise
which is un
unmodeled um and you have somebody
that's not ready yeah
um so the players
so all the players are linear regression
we said they different feature
engineering uh so we have six players we
have the optimal players who just use
every feature in their cubic power just
as we said he can model the best that's
possible up until the noise
um in every player n
he uses cubic power for every feature
except the nth feature
so
the first player
uh
he uses
the first feature as this
and the other feature the same
feature engineering
um
so what that will give us so the first
observation that's important that's is
that every player
n is better than the next one why is
that
because the coefficients we use
we know in linear regressions that if
the features have the same scales the
coefficient is pretty much the like the
feature importance of that feature
so the player n
uh
he sees like a distorted uh feature
of n because
let's say feature number five is the
most important because his coefficient
is five
we will get that
player five is the worst because his
distorted feature is the most important
feature
this was supposed to be in the box so
that doesn't mean anything
but uh yeah so we we have the same
information which means that's why i use
the cubic power so the reason is if we
use some scaling or some translation of
the feature
uh it would just be
the same model basically because the
linear regression is uh invariant to
those kinds of um
feature engineering
but a cubic power if we would would have
take
like a square so power of two we would
get not the same information because
it's not a one-to-one function right so
uh
yeah
um
yeah so players are good in different
areas that's
i'm not going to get into it but one
optimal player is what we said so yeah
cool
so the first thing is i would have a
data set and i'll try to
uh
obviously split it to train and chest
and then
do some
modeling and
in the training
um
if i would wanna assess like
how good my model is i could just plot
uh
this this graph which has the prediction
in the the x-axis i'm sorry that's too
small but uh the x-axis is the
predictions the y-axis is the label and
we can see that and the black line is
just one to one
so uh we can see that the trend looks
okay it's kind of hard to say if we're
good on average
um
but it looks pretty good if you want to
see
um okay one other thing this is two
players so i'm looking at player four
which is the worst player
and i'm looking at the optimal player
which is obviously the the best one
so if i would put a gun to your head and
ask you who's better you might say the
the orange one
but the differences are not that big
right
i mean
doesn't doesn't look like something
uh very different just a small advantage
um
if you would want to see
whether we're calibrated and whether we
are right on average
we could just bin the
all the predictions by the
the model prediction
and calculate the average of the
predictions the average of the label and
just see if we're uh pretty much okay
and here we can see we're pretty much
okay so and this is the worst player so
you can you can assume that all players
are pretty much calibrated so
if i would just do back testing on my uh
on my data set um even when splitting to
test and everything
i would look pretty okay so that that
what this basically means is that when i
uh predict 65
all the items i predict 65 on has an
average
value of 65 some would be higher some
would be lower but on average that would
be 65. so
that what what actually makes me believe
that my strategy could work and my
profit would be neutral and this will be
sustainable and everything
questions
okay can you expect again why n is
better than n minus one yeah um so the
data generating process
was uh using
all the features were sampled from the
same normal distribution
and the coefficients that we used to
generate the labels were one two three
four five
okay is that uh
so yeah
just to finish the
finished descendant so um
that means that feature
n is is uh or feature five is the most
important
because it is the most crucial for the
labeling of the label
this is how linear regression works but
if if that's not intuitive just take my
word for it okay
yeah what about the discussion you need
also
if you engage with list to estimate how
far you will be from the on the line
yeah that's a next question whether you
estimate of the error rate
is unbiased okay you mean looking at the
variance of the prediction yeah so
that's good that that's something i
would want to do but let's assume
there's i buy a lot of items and the
variance is pretty small so
i uh i assume that the
the average um
goes to the main pretty quickly so
that's let's say that's not problem but
that's a good question
so if you will look at a regression
metric
like the most common regression metric
for regression is r square
we can see that
first we see
the sorting that we would have expected
we see that the optimal is the best and
uh as we said player 0
is
is best after it because it sees
the least important feature distorted
and player 4 is the worst but an
interesting thing here to note is that
the optimal player doesn't seem like off
the charts right it seems as far from
player zero
as much as player one is from player
zero so it's just
because we we know the the data
generated the data generating process we
know that there's something different
about
uh the optimal player but if you just
look at the predictions and their
accuracy you just
um you would just believe that it's the
best player if it wasn't around player 0
would be pretty much the same i'll show
that's not the case
okay so i did back testing i'm pretty
happy with my model i'm pretty
calibrated i see that on average i'm
pretty accurate so
i i mean i can expect my strategy to
pretty much work
now's the fun part okay so the market
opens so right until now i was back
testing
i'm pretty happy with myself
but right now the market opens
which means that um
i get features about new items right
and
a lot of other players get the same
features and everyone
uses their own model which they used and
they were all happy with their models
and they bid the their own predictions
and obviously the highest bidder wins
and
right now we'll see what happens to my
predictions
so that's that's
a very interesting graph so this is
basically the same graph we saw about um
just uh beating the
meaning all the items by the predictions
and taking the mean before we saw we
were right on the black line which is
one to one which means that when i
predict
uh x
so all the items i predicted x on on
average would be x
so now we see that's not the case for a
lot of actors so what we see in this
graph is the same graph x
the x-axis is the min prediction
the y-axis is the main label
the black line is one-to-one and every
every color is a different player so
first you can see that
all of the all of the colors are beneath
the
the black line right except the blue one
the blue one you can't see i'm sorry but
the blue one is the the optimal player
okay
and all the else are other players
so first we see the worst models have
higher bias you can't see that here but
you'll see it in a moment so
so here we can see the relative
difference so what you see here is that
when the optimal player on average
predicts something he gets
um
less than a percent
0.16 percent above what he predicted
um but all the others uh see quite a
significant decrease so player zero uh
he gets uh
1.7 less than what he expected and
player four
uh goes all the way to minus six percent
you can imagine that when you're trying
to do investing
that's a bad thing that's not what you
want
so
so those are the biases and we see the
same
uh order that we would have expected so
worst models does the player four are
worse than the best models
um so the first thing i think should be
asked is
maybe it's because of the the optimal
player right because the optimal player
i don't know he's the best and maybe he
takes all the good books
and uh
and
and this phenomenon is basically because
of him
so if we did the same simulation without
the optimal
um the optimal player we would get
something pretty interesting we would
get that
all the players still have a significant
bias even the best one
so as i said before if you only look at
the data
and you see the the optimal player and
all the other players and they all seem
on the same kind of spectrum right
but if you remove the optimal player you
could still think about player 0 to be
the best one so he shouldn't suffer the
curse
but he still
has significant curse and all the others
it's a little smaller than before but
but still significant
so we see there's something different
here and we're trying
we're starting to get some intuition
about what's what's the what's the deal
so yeah
okay so
like the next question i think is is
interesting is whether this is because
there's difference between the players
right
um because you can think about it if we
have let's say we're buying a book okay
and this book really uh its value is 100
and some player offers 10 right i can
make a profit on that item right because
if i if i offer more than
um
sorry the other way around the value is
ten dollars and he offers one hundred
dollars right so i can make a profit on
that item because if i offer more than
100 i obviously uh lose a lot of money
and if i offer less than 10 i'm i'm not
going to get it so
so there's no way i can benefit from
that item so maybe if there's a lot of
shitty players
i'm just i'm not able to to do it right
so
to make uh to simulate
um
players that have there are good that
are equally good
we would change the data generation
process and have all the coefficients
be equal one
and uh basically we'll see the same so
we'll see that the optimal player is
still spot on average and all the others
have still have bias they have the same
bias we can
know it from symmetry
but yeah an equal bias right
okay so
the next question will be okay so i've
done the whole thing and five years have
fast and i've known my bias and now i
want to correct it right so i know that
every time i predict i don't know 70
dollars the real value is actually 67 so
i can just decrease three dollars for
every prediction and this should be fine
right because of
the linearity of expectancy
um
so the first thing is what if everyone
corrects so the market opens after five
years
everyone um
suddenly realized they they have a bias
they all corrected what happens
still we still have significant bias
uh so the the upper table is before the
correction and the low one is
after um
but if we if you're trying to do a
little something a bit harder let's say
i'm the only smart guy in the room and
i'm the only one who realized i can
correct the bias and no one else
corrected the bias
and
i expect to be good and
voila i'm still bad so here i'm player
two you can see that my bias
did decrease the most uh between
everyone else but
but it didn't solve the problem so so
that's kind of weird right because
because if i
i mean in in general if we have some
bias and predictions we know that on
average if i just
uh shift with that bias i won't have any
bias anymore so
that's
why does that happen so
so this is where it gets interesting
because this is
this is something really crucial to
understand about the the whole problem
so in
in regular machine learning and modeling
and statistics
as i said it would have worked
but here
what i can observe is only the average
bias of all the items i won right
but actually when i fix the bias that
means that
whenever i predict 60 uh whenever i
predict x i bid x minus the bias
i actually win new items right
i or
more specifically
i
right now i win a subset of the items i
want before right
so that changes the distribution that's
why
that's why it doesn't work
and uh
what else we can observe is that the
item i lose
by fixing the bias
are actually the items where i had the
least bias right
so if i
if i uh
let's say my bias is one dollar so i
predict 70 and i
uh bid 69
okay so
all the items i didn't win right now uh
were item
items that i was just uh
i was just overestimating by one dollar
right all the items i overestimated by
more than one dollar i still win them
right so basically
what we see here is that
the bias and the the overestimation is
different between different
um items because of the features and how
we did the feature engineering and
everything
um and that makes it uh pretty hard to
estimate what is the real bias how to
really solve it right
so
but we did see that if we
fix the bias
i do get better right i do get a little
bit better so
um
so the obvious question would be if we
try to fix it
iteratively right
um
would i eventually get to a place where
i actually predict uh the actual mean
value
so the the
the answer is yes so what you see here
is the x axis is the correction round
and the the y uh axis is the bias
and you can see that i started pretty
low um but i converge to zero pretty
fast after i don't know
eight nine rounds
uh prob the number of rounds is probably
dependent on the specific problem but
um but we do see that we're able to
to correct it eventually but it takes a
bit time and it depends on the other
player
okay so
i think i'll end with that but
we'll try to just explain
what
what is actually the problem
so
let's say
we look at a very simple problem where
there is one item
and we all
um
try to assess its value we all we all
assess the same mean but with different
uh with the even with the same noise
so the true value here would be just um
the blue line okay
and you can think about it that
all the beatings will be just sampled
from this distribution
and uh and obviously the winning bit
would be the maximum of all the all the
samples from this distribution
and uh
obviously as
as as we have more players in the in the
game and as the
the
the variance of this distribution will
be higher
the
the probability of all the biddings to
be lower than than the actual value is
very small
so basically
we won't have the
large numbers rule where
where the minuses
actually get cancelled with the pluses
and and we converge to the true value
so another way of saying it is that
um
we actually when we train a model we
we
try to predict the expected value
conditioned on the features right the
expected label condition on the features
but what we actually observe is the
expectancy conditioned on
on the features and conditioned on
winning
so
this is what we usually try to predict
um not always it depends on the loss
function but usually we try to predict
the expectancy condition on the features
or on the covariate whatever
your gem is
um
but this
in general does not equal to
to the expected value
uh conditioned on the x and on winning
so
this single bit of whether we won the
auction or not
actually gives us a lot of information
in most cases
this actually gives us
some intuition about why why the why the
optimal player doesn't show the same
dynamics as the other players right so
we can see that
the optimal player actually uh
has this
independency between uh
between the
regarding to the conditioning on the
winning and this is why
he doesn't show the same bias even
even though when he's not around the
best player does show the
this bias
so uh
so yeah and then again and naive
training
generally misses this conditionality so
uh
um
so summing things up
um fixing bias
on average quirks uh it's but it's not
trivial
it's hard to assess the real bias
because when you fix the bias
the items you actually win changes so
that means the distribution changes
and we can use features uh to get
information about the curse itself
um
yeah we need to predict the conditional
expectancy condition on winning the item
and
this is actually interesting so this is
why why is it so hard so
when we usually train a model um
we have some data we feed it into the
training process
and uh
we get a model but here we need a model
that needs to learn something that is
dependent on itself right i need to have
a model that predicts something
that is dependent on the model winning
so
as a model i'm not able to do that
because i don't exist yeah right so this
is why this is
this is kind of complicated and hard uh
when you have
game theoretic uh auctions it is
possible it's like solving uh an
equation where x depends on itself and
you can just wiggle things around and
make it make it work work
um
but yeah
you might be able to approximate it
um there were other slides i left them
out because i knew we wouldn't get it so
thank you very much for listening i hope
this wasn't too much um
i would be happy to answer some
questions until you
okay so
should i repeat the question yeah so uh
this gentleman
asked what would have happened if the
the feature engineering were the other
way around right yeah so basically it
was it was exactly the same so yeah the
first time actually the first time i did
it is just the the player n
i mean the real model was just a linear
combination of the coefficients with no
cubic power and every other player had
one feature that was to the cubic power
so i think i'm not sure that exactly
what you asked but if so
it shows exactly the same dynamics i
chose this because this is more
intuitive because
the cubic power is like doing feature
engineering and why would someone do a
feature engineering that is worse than
using this thing depending on its price
yeah but
basically the answer is yes it will be
exactly the same
um okay so the question was what would
be the strategy to to fix the bias
like the optimal way to fix the bias
what's duration what's the optimization
what do you mean by ratio you said you
fixed uh every iteration
0.75 right
oh okay yeah so the reason i used yeah i
didn't get into it the reason the the
bias fixing was 75
is not because it's optimal or whatever
because uh when you fix too much bias
you end up not winning any loans and
then you don't have any loans to
calculate the bias on so this could have
been any number it depends on the number
of items
it's just a numerical thing
there might be better ones
actually
it's pretty safe to say that taking
a higher than 100 would be better
because we see that we
always undershoot the bias right because
of the dynamics we showed so
so yeah basically it's pretty safe to
say that more than 100 is better i'm not
sure which is the the best
but i can say that there are a lot of
other better ways to do it than to just
fix it iteratively it was just for
explaining stuff
thank you very much enjoy